je pense que l'objectif est bon maintenant d'accord pour
revenir à une fois
et peut-être suivre quelques pistes que vous connaissez
et
obtenir les pistes au début
c'est une bonne idée nous trouverons des
pauses qui s'inclinent comme là-
bas et je descends juste les pistes
debout  à droite légèrement
voir la bière dans un instant
elle est partie
où est-elle
donne-moi des productions où elle est il y a-t-il
à une heure deux heures
peu importe
deux heures  à
droite
peut-être juste euh
commencer ici
peut-être monter haut si nous pouvons regarder en bas
ouais
monter à euh 300 pieds au-dessus de la
même distance que nous sommes mais au-dessus
peut-être le moment où la mère était vraiment
volage l'autre jour parce qu'il avait le
bébés et c'est une bière plus ancienne qui
n'a pas trop
vu d'hélicoptères avant qui
s'en fiche vraiment c'est drôle d'
accord vous venez de suivre ici je
ne veux pas de cercle je veux juste
bien planer je ne veux pas juste faire
le tour je ne  je ne pense pas d'accord d'accord
prêt je viens juste de tourner autour de faire
sceller la caméra d'accord
essayez le doubleur
étranger
d'accord revenons à une fois
toujours pas en train d'attendre que le phoque
s'en fiche de l'
arrière de l'hélicoptère besoin de déjeuner aussi d'accord arrêtez d'
enregistrer